[Music]
what's up guys what a [ __ ]
we got exciting news for you remember
we're posting about danger boys our
pilot that we've been working on
the whole time about street gangs in the
six
to six but in a comedic way well guess
what we're going to release it on
patreon for a short
30 days starting april 1st that's right
but you have to go to the 10
tier and hit them with the 10 to what do
they get bam
okay guess what the 10 tier is pretty
awesome because not only do you get
all of the newest episodes of jk news
but you also get the just kidding party
that we've been playing around here
with david and all the exciting people
like anthony we had a dance off
it's pretty wild man we're bringing back
the old school just
to tickle your fancy and uh on top of
that
you get danger boys is gonna be released
on april 1st
and it's only going to be on april and
then we're going to like
maybe take it out and it may and then
maybe and then maybe we're not even
going to show you guys until
a long time and then we're going to show
it yep and we're going to show you only
for 30 days okay and last year before
this whole covet stuff hit
we were uh talking with hulu yep uh
netflix comedy central they were all
interested in danger boys at the time
yep so you're about to watch something
that other studios were interested in
yep
not get made but interested in no no no
because the whole thing is
kovit came along and they got
yeah they got a huge extra venti latte
and stuck it up our ass
and said [ __ ] you guys you can't do your
college tours anymore
yeah and then we said you know what we
need to release these somewhere
it's like a a fart that's been trapped
in our intestines
for two years so now we're gonna release
this far on patreon for a short 30 days
so you actually go check that out
yep and hope you guys like it i see you
there baby
bye bye the san gabriel valley
known for its dim sum boba shops
and games you want to see some real
gangster [ __ ]
see that house right there you about to
witness a home invasion robbery
oh cops happy birthday cops happy
birthday
[Music]
hey what's up i'm ben i'm the leader of
the danger boys
we need to be the most dangerous gang
and the sgv
danger boys ninja boy what the [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
all right sorry just chuck it up with
that man [ __ ] man you're gonna really
ruin our reputation you got to think
about that [ __ ]
that's not [ __ ] gangster is it medium
gangster
what the [ __ ] are you doing here kenny
what's with all the cameras
things are changing you should have
documented about me everybody get that
what's up y'all i'm tyrone gangster
rapper extraordinaire the
they call me mouse how did i meet then i
was actually in community college
there were these uh these really big
scary dudes luckily then
saw me and he backed me up man
after that he took me under his wing and
he enrolled me into the gangster life
man that guy is such a gangster bro
[Music]
you know what it means to be a [ __ ]
real man these days
a gangster full like me
you don't even bother coming home okay
if you don't get the couch you lazy [ __ ]
and don't forget to put the clothes in
the dryer like i tell you my wife says
you guys can't come over unless i get a
new couch cause the cat peed all over
the old one and [ __ ]
every day he go outside boss all his
friend
he come here he know my hell my rule
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
danger boy darling
family atlantic food garfield hey las
tunis saturnus
danger boy boy
boy yo danger boy shut the [ __ ] up
you